Sus autos,
el sistema de calefacción en sus casas,
sus cocinas a gas.
La mayor parte de la energía que usamos
viene de combustibles fósiles
que generan un par de problemas.
Primero, hay suministros limitados
de combustibles fósiles,
por eso, cuanto más usamos, menos tenemos.
Y segundo, el uso de combustibles fósiles
es la principal causa del cambio climático
porque libera grandes cantidades
de dióxido de carbono a la atmósfera.
Los biocombustibles provienen de fuentes
naturales y renovables como las plantas,
por eso tienen el potencial
de reducir nuestra dependencia
de esos combustibles fósiles limitados
y reducir el riesgo del cambio climático.
Casi todo el biocombustible
hoy se hace con maíz
que, fermentado, produce etanol.
Pero tenemos un suministro
limitado de este grano,
de modo que no soluciona
la parte del dilema
del suministro limitado.
Además, cultivar granos
insume muchos recursos.
Otro intento.
Una posible solución:
El uso de celulosa en vez
de maíz para producir etanol.
La celulosa es mucho más abundante que el maíz
y producirla requiere menos energía.
De hecho, ¡es la molécula orgánica
más abundante del planeta!
La celulosa es el ingrediente principal
de la pared celular de una planta.
Las plantas de celulosa la generan
a partir del agua y del dióxido de carbono
durante la fotosíntesis.
Así como el uso de combustibles fósiles
produce dióxido de carbono,
el uso de etanol a base de celulosa
podría ayudar a eliminar
dióxido de carbono de la atmósfera.
El principal obstáculo es que
la molécula de celulosa
—una larga cadena conectada de azúcar glucosa
protegida por una funda molecular resistente—
es difícil de romper.
Crear etanol a base de celulosa
implica primero quitar la funda protectora
y luego descomponer la celulosa
en sus moléculas individuales de glucosa.
Sólo una vez que hemos desempaquetado
cada molécula de glucosa,
podemos empezar la fermentación.
Pero algunos microorganismos,
como las bacterias o los hongos,
descomponen la celulosa
en energía todo el tiempo.
Por ejemplo, las vacas lecheras comen alimentos
como heno o alfalfa, que están llenos de celulosa.
Los microbios que viven en sus estómagos
producen una enzima llamada celulasa,
que rompe las moléculas de celulosa,
así la vaca puede usar el remanente de energía.
Los investigadores estudian ahora
este tipo de microorganismos
y esperan encontrar mejores maneras
de descomponer la celulosa
y poder usarla para nuestras
propias necesidades energéticas.
La solución, piensan ellos,
yace en encontrar microbios
en la naturaleza que produzcan
el tipo de enzimas de celulasa
que necesitamos.
Este proceso de buscar
especies en la naturaleza
que produzcan productos de valor
se llama bioprospección.
Para probar si una muestra de microbios
puede descomponer efectivamente
la celulosa o no,
los investigadores primero cultivan
microbios en un tubo de ensayos.
Luego añaden una fuente de celulosa
como única forma de energía.
Si el microbio no puede producir celulasa
y descomponer la celulosa,
el tubo de ensayos quedará sin cambios.
Pero si el microbio produce las enzimas
que estamos buscando,
podrá descomponer la celulosa,
usarla para producir energía,
y desarrollarse en el tubo de ensayo.
Si nuestra muestra microbiana
puede descomponer
la celulosa del tubo de ensayo,
existe una posibilidad
de que podamos crear
una fuente de combustible
renovable y sustentable
para nuestros autos con celulosa.